Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What is coercive control and how might you know if you or someone you care about is in a coercive control relationship? What things might you notice which might give you an early indication
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。什么是强制控制？如果你或你关心的人正处于强制控制的关系中，你该如何察觉？你可能会注意到哪些迹象，从而让你初步判断
that something is not quite right here? I am joined by my guest today Chrissy Roberts as we explore all of this and beyond. I hope you find this so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, one of the beautiful things about this podcast is that we can cover really important topics that are useful for both people working in mental health but also the general population too and this is one of those episodes where whatever you're watching this for you can absolutely benefit and learn even I have had some really helpful join the dots moments during the episode today.
这里有些不对劲？今天我的嘉宾克丽丝·罗伯茨（Chrissy Roberts）将和我一起探讨这些问题以及更多内容。希望这对你有所帮助。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。这个播客的美妙之处在于，我们可以涵盖对心理健康从业者和普通大众都非常有用的重要话题。无论你是出于什么原因收听，你都能从中受益并学到东西。即使是我，在今天的节目中也有一些非常有启发性的“豁然开朗”的时刻。
So I hope you will have the same. I would love to know what yours are. Please do connect with me on socials. Please do like, subscribe, comment during the episode if you are watching on YouTube. I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Chrissie. Hi, Chrissie. Hello, nice to be here. Thank you for having me. Oh, you're so welcome. Thank you for reaching out to me on LinkedIn. It was initially to discuss how powerful and resonant you'd found the episode with Alexandra when I was talking
所以我希望你也能有同样的收获。我很想知道你的感悟是什么。请务必在社交媒体上与我联系。如果你是在YouTube上观看，请点赞、订阅并在节目下方评论。我期待在节目结束后与你交流。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾克丽丝。你好，克丽丝。你好，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。哦，不用客气。谢谢你在领英上联系我。最初是因为你觉得我和亚历山德拉（Alexandra）讨论
about complex PTSD and related OCD and that has resonated with you because it's kind of a conversation that's really important but also because of your own lived experience of coercive control. Yeah definitely and I think it was it was really refreshing to see kind of the conversation being had around complex PTSD. Yeah thank you for your kind comments about that episode. So you are a research assistant for a university but you're not researching this area currently but understandably you know when we have had lived experience of something it can become something we become passionate about supporting others in but also raising awareness so that people feel less isolated and more knowledgeable about the signs and what's normal and I have some lived experience of grief
复杂性创伤后应激障碍（C-PTSD）及相关强迫症（OCD）的那期节目非常有力量且引起了共鸣，这触动了你，因为这不仅是一个非常重要的对话，也因为你本人有遭受强制控制的亲身经历。是的，绝对是这样。我觉得看到关于复杂性创伤后应激障碍的讨论真的让人耳目一新。是的，谢谢你对那期节目的好评。你现在是一所大学的研究助理，虽然目前研究的不是这个领域，但可以理解的是，当我们有某种亲身经历时，它往往会成为我们热衷于支持他人并提高公众意识的动力，这样人们就不会感到那么孤立，也能更了解什么是正常的迹象。我本人也有一些关于悲伤的
that I've woven into my work as well and I really want people to feel less alone in that because it can be awful if you feel like something is just happening to you and is that the case for you Chrissie that you're really wanting to open up the narrative around coercive control? Yeah, definitely. And I think that this particular type of domestic abuse was only criminalised almost 10, not even 10 years ago now. So it's really something that as a society, we've not quite got our heads around. I don't think that one of the most dangerous things about it is it's something that builds up over time it's very much a pattern of behavior and as a victim it's very difficult to recognize that that's happening to you so I think by raising awareness it's just kind of you know having these conversations so that maybe listeners can reflect and maybe think about you know their own
亲身经历，我也将其融入到了我的工作中。我真的希望人们在面对这些时能感到不再孤单，因为如果你觉得某些事情只是莫名其妙地发生在你身上，那会非常糟糕。克丽丝，你是否也正是因为这样，才非常希望能公开讨论强制控制的话题呢？是的，绝对是。而且我认为这种特殊的家庭暴力直到不到10年前才被定为犯罪。所以作为一个社会，我们还没有完全理解它。我认为它最危险的一点在于，它是随着时间推移逐渐形成的，这是一种行为模式。作为受害者，很难意识到自己正在经历这些。所以我认为通过提高意识，进行这些对话，也许能让听众反思，并思考一下
thoughts and feelings and about a relationship they might be in because it's just these questions that you have to be confronted with about the situation. Yeah absolutely and I think one of the beautiful things about making this in a psychology podcast is that people might be listening or watching because they're thinking well this might help me therapeutically but it might also help them now but it might help them to be alert and aware early on if actually a relationship they've even entered now becomes coercive because their kind of radar is that much more tuned in. So, you know, I think we've got a really powerful platform here. But before we go too much further, could you kind of try and define for our audience what coercive control is? So coercive control is a crime since
他们自己的想法和感受，以及他们可能身处的关系，因为这些问题是你必须面对的现实。是的，绝对是。我认为将这些内容制作成心理学播客的美妙之处在于，人们收听或观看可能是因为觉得这在治疗上对自己有帮助，或者这能帮助他们现在就保持警惕，如果他们刚进入的一段关系开始变得具有强制性，他们的“雷达”会更加敏锐。所以，我认为我们这里有一个非常有影响力的平台。但在深入探讨之前，你能为我们的听众定义一下什么是强制控制吗？强制控制自
2015. It was introduced under section 76 of the Serious Crimes Act and it is defined by repeated and continued behaviour that is coercive or controlling towards a person who you're personally connected with. The sort of behaviours we're talking about, wide-ranging, often very subtle behaviours that ultimately aim to control the way a person thinks, the way a person behaves, the way a person sees themselves. Often it will make the person isolated, so make them lose contact with their friends or family. Often it will make them have quite a negative view of themselves and affects people's self-concept and one of the biggest things is usually affects people's self-esteem and sense of self-worth and they become very much codependent and very attached to the abuser and that makes it
2015年起被定为犯罪。它是在《严重犯罪法》第76条下引入的，定义为对与你有个人联系的人进行重复且持续的强制或控制行为。我们所说的这类行为范围很广，通常是非常微妙的行为，最终目的是控制一个人的思维方式、行为方式以及自我认知。这通常会使受害者变得孤立，失去与朋友或家人的联系。这往往会使他们对自己产生相当负面的看法，影响个人的自我概念。其中最严重的影响通常是损害人们的自尊心和自我价值感，使他们变得非常依赖并紧紧依附于施暴者，这使得
really difficult to then escape the situation. One of the aspects that makes it a crime is that the perpetrator ought to know that their behavior will have a serious effect on the victim. And that's a really tricky thing. Yeah, absolutely. And I think I'm right in saying that almost can be that trying to reinforce the coupleness of being a team, you know, a complete team. Well, we don't need anyone else. So don't need to see your mum or we don't need to see your friends because, you know, we're enough as we are. So you might not almost realise that they're being edged out and the bubble of just the two of you is being prioritised until years down the line maybe when you suddenly realise it's just very insular. Yeah definitely I think your partner tends to have strong negative opinions about your friends or your family so very subtle comments about like the intentions of your friends
之后想要逃离这种处境变得非常困难。使其成为犯罪的一个方面是，施暴者应当知道他们的行为会对受害者产生严重影响。这是一个非常棘手的问题。是的，绝对是。而且我认为我说得没错，这几乎可以被包装成一种强化“二人世界”或“团队感”的方式，你知道，一个完整的团队。“我们不需要其他人。所以不需要见你的妈妈，也不需要见你的朋友，因为我们在一起就足够了。”所以你可能几乎意识不到自己正在被排挤，而你们两人的“泡沫”被置于首位，直到多年后，你突然意识到这种关系变得非常封闭。是的，绝对是。我认为你的伴侣往往会对你的朋友或家人持有强烈的负面看法，比如对你朋友
or family and kind of planting those seeds of doubt in your head about who's on your side and who isn't and the narrative is often very much that part of your partner is the only person you can trust and then built up over time often over a matter of years people in this sort of situation will find themselves with no one other than abuser or partner. Yeah, absolutely. So it's really undermining yourself, your own confidence and kind of starting paranoia really for kind of how trustworthy other people or their advice might be. I think it's important that we state that this is a gender neutral crime. This can happen with male to female, female to female, male to male, you know, whatever. It's like this can affect anybody of any background, of any culture,
或家人的意图发表非常微妙的评论，并在你心中种下怀疑的种子，让你分不清谁是站在你这边的。这种叙事往往是你的伴侣是你唯一可以信任的人。随着时间的推移，通常是几年下来，处于这种处境的人会发现自己除了施暴者或伴侣之外，身边空无一人。是的，绝对是。所以这真的在削弱你自己、你的自信，并引发一种偏执，怀疑其他人或他们的建议是否可信。我认为我们必须声明，这是一种性别中立的犯罪。这可能发生在男对女、女对女、男对男之间，无论背景、文化、
of any faith. I think many people might have this in their minds as a male to female crime. And many years ago now, Coronation Street had a storyline where Gail Platt and her family were being really controlled by Gail's new partner, Richard Hillman, which did not end up well for the family, I have to say. I think it ended up worse for Richard from memory. I think he ended up driving his car into some water. But that's not the case. This can happen to anybody. Yeah, definitely. It can be in any relationship too. It's not just a romantic relationship. It's just any relationship where you're kind of personally connected to each other. I think what's really important as well is that often power dynamics come into play quite a lot. So I think particularly young people, people with existing vulnerabilities. So maybe who come from, who have difficult family backgrounds or who have maybe who are struggling with their mental health if you've got people that have those sort of existing vulnerabilities I think are particularly vulnerable to coercive control
信仰如何。我认为许多人可能认为这是一种男对女的犯罪。多年前，《加冕街》（Coronation Street）曾有一个剧情，盖尔·普拉特（Gail Platt）和她的家人被盖尔的新伴侣理查德·希尔曼（Richard Hillman）严密控制，我必须说，这对那个家庭来说结局并不好。我记得对理查德来说结局更糟。我记得他最后开车冲进了水里。但事实并非如此。这可能发生在任何人身上。是的，绝对是。它也可能发生在任何关系中。不仅仅是浪漫关系。任何你与之有个人联系的关系都可能发生。我认为同样重要的是，权力动态往往起着很大的作用。所以我认为特别是年轻人、有现有脆弱性的人。比如那些来自家庭背景困难，或者可能正在与心理健康问题作斗争的人，如果你有这些现有脆弱性的人，我认为他们特别容易受到强制控制，
because you can be in a position where you're sort of almost looking for guidance so someone that comes along and wants to take over and kind of especially under the guise of looking after you can be really attractive there are lots of people who end up in these sort of situations because they entered the relationship in quite a vulnerable state which was taken advantage of. Gosh that is such an important consideration actually that this doesn't just need to be within an intimate relationship you know a sexual relationship this can be a colleague this can be a friend and there's definite overlap between what you just said there about the vulnerability I don't know if you've done the prevent training for kind of anti-radicalization, but it's finding the person or the people who are most vulnerable to then be able to exploit. And I also kind of am thinking if people are listening or watching this, perhaps working in a CAM service, so children and young people, sometimes people can be so very controlled by one of their peers which can really affect their mental health as well and I think it's kind of helpful to kind of think that could
因为你可能处于一种正在寻找指导的境地，所以有人出现并想要接管一切，特别是打着“照顾你”的幌子，这可能非常有吸引力。有很多人最终陷入这种境地，是因为他们进入关系时处于相当脆弱的状态，而这种状态被利用了。天哪，这是一个非常重要的考量，事实上，这不仅仅发生在亲密关系（性关系）中，这可能是一个同事，一个朋友。而且你刚才提到的关于脆弱性的内容与“预防”（Prevent）培训（针对反激进化）之间有明确的重叠，即寻找最脆弱的人，然后进行剥削。我也在想，如果人们正在收听或观看这个节目，也许是在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作，有时人们会被同龄人严密控制，这也会严重影响他们的心理健康。我认为将这种情况
be reframed as a coercive relationship actually. Yeah definitely I think that where the onus is often placed on intimate relationships because of the level of contact that you tend to have with that person and how sort of all-encompassing it can be. But it can often be cases of it being between parents and children, you know, adult children and their parents, or kind of, you know, anyone that's kind of living together or in close quarters in particular. It's just something that we need to be more aware of, definitely. We do.
重新定义为强制性关系其实很有帮助。是的，绝对是。我认为虽然人们通常将重点放在亲密关系上，因为你与那个人接触的程度以及这种关系可能具有的全面性，但它也经常发生在父母和子女之间，你知道，成年子女和他们的父母，或者任何住在一起或在狭小空间内的人之间。这确实是我们更需要意识到的事情。我们确实需要。
And actually, I kind of, you know, sometimes you have a realisation, like, oh, yeah, of course that makes sense. But I've only just had it now that potentially you could go down criminal prosecution routes for coercive control from a parent. Like this doesn't need to just be an intimate relationship. And I think that is my first take home point from this episode, actually, Chrissie. Yeah, no, definitely. I think the key thing about it is that it's sort of a pattern of behavior and the effects on the victim serious. So the victim might be isolated, as we said, from their friends and family, might be suffering with their mental health, with their physical health. Because coercive controlling behavior can also be around sort of medical, controlling someone's access to medical, to health care, controlling someone's access to medical, to healthcare, controlling someone's access to
事实上，有时你会有一种顿悟，比如“哦，是的，这当然说得通”。但我刚才才意识到，潜在地，你可以通过刑事起诉途径来处理来自父母的强制控制。这不一定非要是亲密关系。事实上，这确实是我从这期节目中得到的第一个要点，克丽丝。是的，绝对是。我认为关键在于这是一种行为模式，且对受害者造成了严重影响。受害者可能像我们说的那样，与朋友和家人隔绝，可能正在遭受心理健康或身体健康方面的困扰。因为强制控制行为也可能涉及医疗方面，控制某人获得医疗保健的途径，控制某人获得
medications that they need, and a reproductive control, so stopping someone from taking the pill. There's all sorts of ways that this sort of behaviour can manifest itself. This is the tricky thing about it, is that it's often a constellation of different tactics that are used in order to keep someone under control. Absolutely. Do we have a sense of why? You know, I want to steer clear of kind of personality diagnoses here, but what do we think that person would get from that? I think it obviously completely depends on the person and the situation, but things often play out in life in the way we relate to each other.
所需的药物，以及生殖控制，比如阻止某人服用避孕药。这种行为的表现方式多种多样。这正是它的棘手之处，它通常是一系列不同的策略，旨在将某人置于控制之下。绝对是。我们知道原因吗？你知道，我想避开人格诊断，但我们认为施暴者能从中得到什么？我认为这显然完全取决于个人和具体情况，但生活中的事情往往以我们相互关联的方式展开。
It probably comes from a place of deep insecurity and of maybe that having quite unhealthy scripts of what relationships are who knows what someone who perpetuates this behavior experienced when they were a child so many things that could be going on behind this and i think as well that the people who perpetrate this sort of behavior are also people we need to be thinking about supporting to stop it to start to break the cycle of it because i think it's quite common as well for people to be in multiple relationships like this so one person will leave and then you know they will move on to the next relationship and kind of fall into the same pattern it's got to be quite a miserable
这可能源于深深的不安全感，或者可能有着非常不健康的关于关系的剧本。谁知道一个实施这种行为的人在童年时期经历了什么？背后可能有很多原因。而且我认为，实施这种行为的人也是我们需要考虑支持的对象，以阻止它，打破这种循环。因为我认为人们陷入多段这样的关系也很常见，一个人离开后，他们会进入下一段关系，并陷入同样的模式。这一定是一种非常悲惨
and unhappy way to relate to people you know, as psychologists, we would see we will be able to work with people who are perpetrators as well as just victims. Yeah, absolutely. It's not just that we want to help the victim here. We want to kind of open up some insights, some reflections, some acknowledgement that this is not okay. This isn't an okay way to treat people definitely and i think that perspective of the abuser is probably quite an anxiety riddled existence really you know worrying constantly about what another person is doing what another person's thinking how another person's behaving who they're speaking to so i think there must be
且不快乐的与人相处的方式。你知道，作为心理学家，我们不仅能帮助受害者，也能与施暴者一起工作。是的，绝对是。我们不仅想帮助这里的受害者。我们想提供一些洞察、一些反思、一些承认，即这种行为是不对的。这绝对不是对待人的正确方式。而且我认为施暴者的视角可能是一种充满焦虑的存在，真的。你知道，不断担心另一个人在做什么、在想什么、在表现什么、在和谁说话。所以我认为一定有
room for people who are perpetuating this sort of behaviour to want to change the way that they're behaving in relationships. Yeah, absolutely. And I think the very tricky thing about all relationships really is that they are multiple parts. So that can make it extra tricky when you're looking at potentially dissolving a coercive relationship because of course a partner might also at times be very loving or if it's an intimate partner might be very sexually gratifying for you or if it's a friend or even if it's a partner might be really fun to go out on day trips with and to do things with together and so it's not just that simple thing of kind of recognizing the coercive element and ending that relationship. Like it's very involved and it's all interwoven, isn't it?
空间让那些实施这种行为的人想要改变他们在关系中的行为方式。是的，绝对是。而且我认为所有关系中最棘手的事情是它们是多方面的。所以当你考虑潜在地结束一段强制性关系时，这会变得格外棘手，因为当然，伴侣有时也可能非常深情，或者如果是亲密伴侣，可能在性方面非常令人满足，或者如果是一个朋友，甚至是一个伴侣，可能一起去一日游、一起做事情会非常有趣。所以这不仅仅是识别强制因素并结束关系那么简单。这非常复杂，而且交织在一起，不是吗？
Yeah, that's a really good point, because often something that stops victims from being able to see what's happening like. They might kind of really not talk to you or they might be quite emotionally abusive, call you names, make you feel bad about yourself. But the rest of the time, while you're behaving in ways that they approve of, that will often be rewarded by affection. I think what's often quite a misunderstood term, but love bombing. So sort of really over the top displays of affection and of of love for someone you know being really overwhelmed by maybe being even being bought gifts so it's almost like the victim becomes trained to behave in certain ways and that can be really subtle ways like the way that they dress the way that they speak even lots of you know really subtle aspects of who they are
是的，那是一个非常好的观点，因为通常阻止受害者看到正在发生什么的事情是……他们可能不和你说话，或者可能在情感上非常虐待你，辱骂你，让你对自己感觉很糟糕。但在其他时间，只要你的行为方式是他们认可的，通常会得到爱抚的奖励。我认为这是一个经常被误解的术语，即“爱情轰炸”（love bombing）。也就是对某人进行非常夸张的爱抚和爱的展示，你知道，被礼物淹没，甚至被买礼物。所以这几乎就像受害者被训练以某种方式行事，这可能是非常微妙的方式，比如他们的穿着方式、说话方式，甚至他们身上许多非常微妙的方面
over time just sort of become molded absolutely and in this modern age of, you know, really subtle aspects of who they are over time just sort of become moulded. Absolutely. And in this modern age of ours, you know, if someone buys us something that we like, we might put that on social media. And so we might text our friends or WhatsApp them. And so, you know, for all intents and purposes, your friends and your family might see them as being a really good, generous partner, you know, or you've bought them a trip to, you know, New York. Wow. You know or you've bought them a trip to you know new york wow you know you've been out to that michelin starred restaurant oh i've never been there that's fancy i'd love to do that what what an amazing boyfriend what an amazing girlfriend and it can
随着时间的推移，只是被塑造了。绝对是。在这个现代时代，你知道，如果有人买了我们喜欢的东西，我们可能会发到社交媒体上。所以我们可能会给朋友发短信或用WhatsApp联系他们。所以，在所有意图和目的上，你的朋友和家人可能会认为他们是一个非常好的、慷慨的伴侣，你知道，或者你给他们买了去纽约的旅行。哇。你知道，或者你给他们买了去纽约的旅行，哇，你知道，你们去了那家米其林星级餐厅，哦，我从来没去过那里，那很高级，我很想去，多么棒的男朋友，多么棒的女朋友。这可能
be tricky to kind of open up that narrative as well like actually that's you know there's maybe another side to the story too and that's this is part of the kind of the walls that are put up around you in terms of and often you know an abuser might literally say well I and bring bring these things up to you when you've done something that they don't like so well I bought you this or well you know I'm a wonderful husband because I did this and I did that and it's very much just kind of used as evidence that you're the one that's in the wrong all the time and that their behavior is actually fine.
很难去揭开那个叙事，事实上，可能还有故事的另一面。这就是围绕在你身边的“墙”的一部分。而且通常，你知道，施暴者可能会在你做了他们不喜欢的事情时，字面上说：“我买了这些东西给你”，或者“你知道，我是个好丈夫，因为我做了这个，做了那个”。这被用作证据，证明你才是那个一直犯错的人，而他们的行为实际上是没问题的。
They must love you because look at all these wonderful things that they've done. It also really cleverly creates this sort of outwards facade for everyone in your life and, you know, on social media, people that you know will look from the outside and think, oh, what a wonderful relationship. You know, they look so happy sort of thing. So when you begin to question, when you begin to notice that maybe there is coercive control happening, it can be really, really difficult to speak to anyone about it, to open up to even a, you know, a really close friend or, you or you know a parent or it can be really
他们一定很爱你，因为看看他们做的所有这些美妙的事情。这也非常聪明地为你的生活中的每个人创造了一种外在的假象，你知道，在社交媒体上，你认识的人会从外面看，认为“哦，多么美妙的关系”。你知道，他们看起来很幸福。所以当你开始质疑，当你开始注意到可能正在发生强制控制时，要和任何人谈论这件事，向一个非常亲密的朋友，或者父母敞开心扉，可能会非常、非常困难。或者这可能非常
difficult to have those conversations because you'll often be met with oh but I thought that they did this for you or I thought that you know I thought you seemed really happy sort of thing so it's often it's all these these things that go on very much behind closed doors between two people that is is just really difficult to try and wrap your head around when you're trying to get out of that situation. Yeah. And, you know, I think as a therapist, as a friend, as a daughter, as a sister, as a mummy, I don't know why that one came last, I guess it's allowing people to speak their truth and not necessarily thinking that you need to rationalize that for them or or thought balance you know we're not doing cbt here if someone says oh i'm not feeling that happy in that relationship we
难以进行那些对话，因为你经常会遇到“哦，但我以为他们为你做了这个”或者“我以为你看起来真的很幸福”之类的话。所以这些事情通常都是在两个人的闭门之后发生的，当你试图摆脱那种处境时，真的很难理清头绪。是的。而且，你知道，我认为作为一名治疗师、朋友、女儿、姐妹、妈妈——我不知道为什么最后一个才说，我想这在于允许人们说出真相，而不一定认为你需要为他们合理化，或者进行“思维平衡”。你知道，我们在这里不是做认知行为疗法（CBT），如果有人说“我在那段关系中感觉不那么快乐”，我们
shouldn't be saying but you've got that trip to paris booked you know it's we it's our job therapeutically and you know personally if it's a personal relationship to really tune in, to really hear and to give space and oxygen to this conversation. Yeah, so I think it's really important to, as you said, focus on how someone feels. If you're the person in the situation thinking, you know, how do I feel? Do I feel happy with this person? Do they make me feel scared? Do I feel comfortable around this person? Am I worrying about what I say all the time? Am I treading on eggshells? Do I feel comfortable around this person? Am I worrying about what I say all the time? Am I treading on eggshells? Do I feel tense and kind of like I'm putting on a show all the time because I'm worried about what this person might do if I sort of show who I really am? That's
不应该说“但你预订了去巴黎的旅行”。你知道，我们的工作，在治疗上，以及在个人关系中，是真正去倾听，去真正听到，并为这种对话提供空间和氧气。是的，所以我认为非常重要的是，正如你所说，关注一个人的感受。如果你是处于这种情况的人，在想“我感觉如何？我和这个人在一起快乐吗？他们让我感到害怕吗？我和这个人在一起感到舒服吗？我一直在担心我说的话吗？我是否如履薄冰？我和这个人在一起感到舒服吗？我一直在担心我说的话吗？我是否如履薄冰？我是否感到紧张，好像我一直在表演，因为我担心如果我展示真实的自己，这个人可能会做什么？”这是
a really key thing if you're to have a conversation with someone who might be in this sort of relationship is to focus entirely on their feelings and not necessarily even towards their partner but towards them set them think a big sign is for people to think that the problems in their relationship are entirely their fault and to almost sort of like hero worship their partner and sort of think oh well no he's wonderful he's done this he's done this and he's you know he's looked after me and stuff and i just can't you know it's this feeling that or this sense that someone feels like everything's their fault all the time that's this just one of the biggest red flags because this sort of
一个非常关键的事情。如果你要和一个可能处于这种关系中的人进行对话，要完全关注他们的感受，而不一定是对他们的伴侣，而是对他们自己。让他们思考。一个很大的迹象是人们认为关系中的问题完全是他们自己的错，并几乎像“英雄崇拜”一样对待他们的伴侣，认为“哦，不，他很棒，他做了这个，他做了这个，他照顾我”等等。我只是不能……这是一种感觉，或者一种认为一切都是自己错的感觉，这只是最大的危险信号之一，因为这种
behavior over time has that effect on someone they just you just sort of become a sponge for all of the blame all the shame that's going around you just sort of absorb so yeah definitely focusing on feelings rather than any sort of specific behavior that you can pinpoint is really important. Yeah, that's such a useful kind of thing to watch out for, actually. Yeah, we're not looking at tangible baubles here. We're looking at actually the things that have happened that have made you feel something uncomfortable or painful or fearful or just unease, you know, that sense of not being able to be yourself. And I think it's really important we just take a moment to really slow everything down here and just have it be vocalized that everybody deserves to be
行为随着时间的推移会对某人产生这种影响，你只是变成了一个吸收所有责备、所有羞耻的海绵。所以，是的，绝对是，关注感受而不是你可以指出的任何特定行为是非常重要的。是的，那确实是一个非常有用的观察点。是的，我们在这里寻找的不是有形的饰品。我们实际上是在寻找那些让你感到不舒服、痛苦、恐惧或仅仅是不安的事情，你知道，那种无法做自己的感觉。而且我认为非常重要的是，我们花点时间真正放慢一切，并大声说出来：每个人都值得
in a relationship or in a friendship that feels reciprocal, fun, warm, compassionate, non-judgmental, not threatening, not scary. Those are not outlandish things to want for your intimate relationships or for your personal or colleague relationships, are they? No, exactly, exactly. And I think that sometimes when you've been in this sort of relationship, you feel very much like you've, you know, the person that you're with is more than you deserve. And that is something that people that perpetuate this sort of behavior will really cling to this sort of, yeah, this sense of like, you're really lucky to have me and no one else would put with you and all of that sort of stuff which really becomes massively internalized and takes many years often for victims to undo that sense of sort of being undeserving of of these these
拥有一段感觉相互尊重、有趣、温暖、富有同情心、不评判、不威胁、不恐怖的关系或友谊。这些对于你的亲密关系或个人或同事关系来说，并不是什么过分的要求，对吧？不，完全正确，完全正确。而且我认为有时当你处于这种关系中时，你会非常觉得你与之在一起的人是你“不配拥有”的。这是那些实施这种行为的人会真正坚持的东西，这种“你很幸运能拥有我，没有别人会忍受你”之类的东西，这真的会被大规模内化，受害者通常需要很多年才能消除那种“不配拥有”这些
really really basic relational needs absolutely yeah we're all deserving of love and regardless of what's come before and regardless of our upbringing, you know, it's safe for us to have functional relationships. And they can absolutely leave ripples of trauma down our own lives and intergenerationally as well when that hasn't happened. But could we think about what a really common term is in the media currently, which is gaslighting. And that seems to be everywhere at the moment what's what's that all about yeah definitely I think people I think it's because it's become so popularized like lots of psychology terms have been often people think it just means basically disagreeing with someone so someone so so you say something and then someone has a
非常、非常基本的关联需求的感觉。绝对是。是的，我们都值得被爱，无论过去发生了什么，无论我们的成长经历如何。我们拥有功能性的关系是安全的。当这种情况没有发生时，它们绝对会在我们自己的生活中以及代际之间留下创伤的涟漪。但我们能思考一下媒体目前的一个非常常见的术语吗？那就是“煤气灯效应”（gaslighting）。这似乎到处都是，那到底是怎么回事？是的，绝对是。我认为是因为它变得非常流行，就像许多心理学术语一样。人们通常认为它基本上意味着与某人意见不合。所以你说了一些话，然后某人有
different view and they're very passionate in that view and try to convince you that you're wrong. And then they think, you know, people will think that's gaslighting. It's much more complex than that, really. It's kind of making someone doubt their reality, basically. So the most obvious sort of example is you say the sky is blue and then someone says to you no it's not it's it's orange and then we'll keep you know keep going at you and going at you until you kind of see yourself starting to like to doubt you know can I see properly can I sort of thing doubting literally doubting your reality and what you perceive so I think examples of that in a relationship would be your partner says something really unkind to you and then will instantly deny it and sort of say, what are you talking about? You've made that up. Gaslighting often kind of makes people struggle a lot with their mental health because it makes you doubt your reality. you start feeling like you're going mad you start mistrusting everything so you start thinking did
不同的观点，并且对那个观点非常热情，试图说服你你是错的。然后他们认为，你知道，人们会认为那是煤气灯效应。它实际上比那复杂得多。它基本上是让某人怀疑自己的现实。所以最明显的例子是，你说天空是蓝色的，然后有人对你说“不，不是，它是橙色的”，然后会一直针对你，直到你发现自己开始怀疑，“我看得清楚吗？”之类的。字面上怀疑你的现实和你所感知的。所以我认为在关系中，这种例子是你的伴侣对你说了一些非常刻薄的话，然后会立即否认，并说：“你在说什么？那是你编造的。”煤气灯效应通常会让人们在心理健康方面挣扎很多，因为它让你怀疑自己的现实。你开始觉得自己要疯了，你开始不信任一切。所以你开始想：“那
that happen you know was that real did you know did they do that so it can be really hard to just have that have a sense of narrative of what's happening in your life a good sign that that's happening to you is if you start feeling the need to which is something that that I've experienced is starting feeling feeling the need to record things so feeling the need to write things down all the time feeling the need to journal or make voice recordings of conversations um even like setting up cctv and stuff just because you need proof and you need kind of something to cling to even if you don't use that to then confront the person and say, no, look, this is what happened. Very much for my own sanity,
发生了吗？那是真的吗？他们做了吗？”所以很难对生活中发生的事情有一个叙事感。一个很好的迹象是，如果你开始感到需要——这也是我经历过的——开始感到需要记录事情。所以感到需要一直写下来，感到需要写日记或进行对话的录音，甚至像安装闭路电视之类的，只是因为你需要证据，你需要一些东西来坚持，即使你不使用它来对抗那个人并说：“不，看，这就是发生的。”这非常是为了我自己的理智，
for me to be able to think, to start to have an idea of, no, that did happen, that they did say that or they did do that. A really dangerous tactic really because of those effects it has on your mental health and on your ability to trust your own thoughts and feelings about a situation. Absolutely that's exactly what I was thinking that almost those recordings or those
为了让我能够思考，开始有一个概念：“不，那确实发生了，他们确实说了那个，或者他们确实做了那个。”这确实是一个非常危险的策略，因为它对你的心理健康以及你信任自己对情况的想法和感受的能力产生了影响。绝对是，这正是我所想的，几乎那些录音或那些
notes you're making are to learn to trust yourself again because you've become so undermined and I know kind of some examples might involve you know finding that your pill packet or some other medication that you're taking, the foil blister is empty and thinking, oh, I sure haven't taken that. And then the partner might say, yeah, you took it standing by the window this morning. You know, I saw you had a conversation whilst you were doing it. And then you might think, oh, okay, I was just distracted, but I don't remember feeling that pill in my mouth. But yeah, okay, it must have happened. Or, you know, you suddenly find the window is open or the door is open and you felt sure that you shut that earlier. And then they kind of would say, well,
你做的笔记是为了学会再次信任自己，因为你已经被严重削弱了。我知道一些例子可能包括：发现你的药片包装或其他你正在服用的药物，铝箔泡罩是空的，然后想：“哦，我确定我没吃那个。”然后伴侣可能会说：“是的，你今天早上站在窗边吃的。我看到你吃的时候还在聊天。”然后你可能会想：“哦，好吧，我只是分心了，但我记不得感觉到那片药在嘴里了。”但“是的，好吧，它一定发生了。”或者，你突然发现窗户是开着的，或者门是开着的，你确定你早些时候关上了。然后他们会说：“
you've left the door open. It can't be me because I wasn't in. And that's not necessarily the case. You know, this could be you being, this could be somebody trying to undermine your confidence in yourself. Yeah. Again, it just, it it feeds into this this sort of narrative of you can't be trusted no one can be trusted I'm the one that knows best I'm the one that has your best interests at heart it's that sort of that sort of power really that over someone's life. Yeah and you know I know that you working as a researcher might be a big fan of an outcome measure are there outcome measures that screen for coercive control? I'm not sure, really. I think it would be something that's, I know that it's in terms of legally, it's something that's really, really notoriously difficult for the
你把门开着了。不可能是因为我不在。”这不一定是事实。你知道，这可能是你被……这可能是有人试图削弱你对自己的信心。是的。同样，它只是……它助长了这种“你不可信，没人可信，我是最了解的，我是最关心你的”叙事。这确实是那种对某人生活的权力。是的，而且你知道，我知道你作为一名研究人员，可能非常喜欢结果测量工具。有没有筛选强制控制的结果测量工具？我真的不确定。我认为这会是……我知道在法律上，这对于
police to investigate and to build up evidence of because it's often so subtle. It's often, you know, these really tiny sort of drops in the ocean almost that build up over time you know into something quite big that has a massive effect on someone but no I don't I think that there's there's certain behaviors that are real red flags that kind of there's no reason why someone can reasonably be doing that so for example you know tracking your car or taking your wages, so like financial control. There's certain things that kind of smoking, more of like a smoking gun type thing, but it's quite, those things are often crimes of themselves. So things like threats to
警察来说是非常、非常臭名昭著的难以调查和收集证据的，因为它通常太微妙了。它通常是……你知道，这些非常微小的“滴水穿石”，随着时间的推移积累起来，变成了一些相当大的东西，对某人产生了巨大的影响。但没有，我认为……有一些行为是真正的危险信号，没有理由让某人合理地做这些事。例如，你知道，追踪你的车或拿走你的工资，比如经济控制。有些事情更像是“确凿证据”类型的东西，但这些事情本身往往就是犯罪。所以像威胁
kill, things like that, it's often a crime of of itself and the real day-to-day damage the the insidious damage of coercive control is in all of those those very small interactions and those those small you know small but constant things that someone will do to undermine your sense of self and your sense of who you are your sense of who you can trust. So I'm not aware of any real test for it. And I think that this is part of the issue with it in terms of recognising coercive control and then the step further in terms of prosecuting it. Yeah, okay.
杀人，诸如此类的事情，这本身往往就是犯罪。而强制控制的日常伤害，那种隐蔽的伤害，在于所有那些非常小的互动，以及那些小的、你知道，小的但持续的事情，某人会做这些来削弱你的自我感，你对你是谁的感知，你对你可以信任谁的感知。所以我不知道有什么真正的测试方法。而且我认为这是它在识别强制控制方面，以及在进一步起诉方面的问题的一部分。是的，好的。
So it's a really, it's hard to define. And yeah, maybe some further research on this would be really useful, possible doctoral project for somebody looking at potentially putting together an outcome measure for this, because that would then open up the conversation, you know, wouldn't it really without having to dig around too deep, because this is not necessarily something that someone would necessarily come to a service wanting to explore. It might be that they're struggling with X, Y, and Z, and then this is actually what's potentially perpetuating the problem, but they wouldn't necessarily be seeking support for that. So, for example, a partner might have
所以它真的很难定义。而且，是的，也许对此进行进一步的研究会非常有用，可能是某人的博士项目，研究潜在地为这个制定一个结果测量工具，因为那将打开对话，不是吗？真的，而不必挖掘得太深，因为这不一定是某人会主动来到服务机构想要探索的事情。可能是他们正在为X、Y和Z挣扎，而这实际上是潜在地加剧问题的因素，但他们不一定会为此寻求支持。例如，伴侣可能
allowed them to go and sort out their postnatal depression or their OCD but what we know that potentially underlying that might be a coercive control issue. Yeah definitely I think it's quite common as well for a perpetrator to really play lean into that mental health aspect and that kind of the vulnerability of the victim because that that then allows them to take up that space and to take up that space as as the savior and the hero and the carer and also sort of because of the stigma around around people with with mental health issues i think it also allows them to have that card to play of oh well you know they're mentally ill or they're you know to undermine their ability to think for themselves again absolutely and you know i think with their ability to think for themselves again. Absolutely. And,
允许他们去解决他们的产后抑郁症或强迫症，但我们知道潜在的根本原因可能是一个强制控制问题。是的，绝对是。我认为施暴者非常倾向于利用心理健康方面，以及受害者的那种脆弱性，这也是很常见的。因为那允许他们占据那个空间，并以“救世主”、“英雄”和“照顾者”的身份占据那个空间。而且，由于围绕心理健康问题的污名化，我认为这也允许他们打出那张牌：“哦，好吧，你知道，他们精神上有病”或者他们……你知道，再次削弱他们独立思考的能力。绝对是，而且你知道，我认为随着他们独立思考的能力再次被削弱。绝对是。而且，
you know, I think with what we were saying about the almost radicalisation, you know, that people are being picked on because they're vulnerable, this is really potentially helpful conversations to be having at a secondary school education level. So the people are beginning to make informed choices about what healthy relationships look like and to kind of make them more immunized for future really so that they're not years down the line you know we don't want them being groomed and exploited and only realizing so many years later that this wasn't okay this this shouldn't have happened this wasn't normal no matter what you were told at the time that's definitely my view of things and why I do the work that I do.
你知道，我认为关于我们所说的几乎是“激进化”，你知道，人们因为脆弱而被选中，这在中学教育层面是非常有帮助的对话。所以人们开始对健康的关系是什么样子做出明智的选择，并使他们对未来产生“免疫”，这样他们就不会在多年后……你知道，我们不希望他们被诱导和剥削，直到多年后才意识到这并不好，这不应该发生，这不正常，无论当时别人对你说了什么。这绝对是我对事情的看法，也是我做我现在所做工作的原因。
With my lived experience, I think ultimately I wouldn't want my daughter to find herself in the sort of situations I've been in. And I think that the key, as you said, is education and awareness and making sure that our children grow up really able to understand and reflect on their own feelings and emotions and have those heard and be able to have safe adults where they can kind of unpick, you know, how they felt in a situation. Because I think a lot of the issue with coercive control is that you'll have many years of feeling very uncomfortable and very unsafe and very unhappy. If you don't trust your thoughts and feelings to begin with because you've not had that solid base of being taught that as a child or it's not been something that's been nurtured in you,
以我的亲身经历来看，我最终不希望我的女儿陷入我曾经经历过的那种境地。我认为关键正如你所说，在于教育和意识，确保我们的孩子在成长过程中真正能够理解并反思自己的感受和情绪，让这些感受被倾听，并能拥有可以信任的成年人，让他们能够梳理自己在某种情境下的感受。因为我认为强制控制问题的很大一部分在于，你可能会在很多年里感到非常不舒服、非常不安全和非常不快乐。如果你一开始就不信任自己的想法和感受，因为你从小没有接受过这方面的基础教育，或者这方面没有得到培养，
you're kind of set up to fail from the start, really. So I think it's really important that just this sort of emotional education is really important. Yeah, and again, it really strengthens the narrative of trying to have a non-judgmental stance, you know, so perhaps a parent might have made it very clear they don't want their child engaging in sexual activity until they're 25 or married or whatever. And somebody has been in a sexual relationship. It's kind of not about that. It's about the fact that actually this has all
那你从一开始就注定会失败。所以我认为这种情感教育非常重要。是的，这再次强化了保持非评判立场的重要性，你知道，也许父母可能已经明确表示他们不希望孩子在25岁或结婚之前发生性行为，而某人却已经有了性关系。这其实不是重点。重点在于，实际上这一切
gone horribly wrong. And I happen to be having sex as well. And it's extricating the feelings of anger or disappointment and actually, again, really trying to tune in to the distress the person is bringing you. This is not okay. Yeah. No, exactly. Thank you so much for your time and for really helping our audience to be illuminated in this really important area. If people want to connect with you, where's the best place that they could do that? LinkedIn and Twitter. I really want to thank you, and I hope that you're being well-supported,
已经变得非常糟糕。而我恰好也在发生性行为。这需要剥离愤怒或失望的情绪，再次真正尝试去关注对方带给你的痛苦。这不对劲。是的。没错，确实如此。非常感谢你抽出时间，帮助我们的听众在这个非常重要的领域获得启发。如果人们想与你联系，最好的方式是什么？领英和推特。我真的想感谢你，希望你在工作和个人生活中都能得到很好的支持，
both at work and personally, and that you can go on and have really happy, healthy, fruitful relationships with everyone around you. Thank you, Maria. Thanks for having me. Oh, you're around you. Thank you, Marianne. Thanks for having me. Oh, you're so welcome. Thank you so much. What a fabulous guest Chrissie was. Thank you so much for your time, Chrissie.
并且能够与周围的每一个人建立真正幸福、健康、富有成效的关系。谢谢你，玛丽亚。谢谢你邀请我。哦，你太客气了。非常感谢。克丽丝真是一位出色的嘉宾。非常感谢你抽出时间，克丽丝。
What has this evoked or resonated for you? Drop me a comment below. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts, please do rate and review. Please do come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent listening on Apple Podcasts, please do rate and review. Please do come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent, which is on Facebook, which is the free and exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions. I hope this has really helped you to understand a bit more about what coercive control is and how you might be able to notice the patterns in yourself or someone that you care about.
这引起了你什么样的共鸣或反思？请在下方给我留言。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，请务必评分和评论。请加入玛丽安·特伦特博士的“有抱负的心理学家”社区，该社区在Facebook上，是玛丽安的动力和心态课程的免费专属家园。我希望这能真正帮助你更多地了解什么是强制控制，以及你如何能够发现自己或你在意的人身上存在的模式。
Thank you so much for your time. If you found today's episode helpful, I think you'll also really like the one I did with Alexandra looking at understanding complex trauma and OCD. Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of
非常感谢你抽出时间。如果你觉得今天的一集很有帮助，我想你也会喜欢我和亚历山德拉关于理解复杂创伤和强迫症的那一集。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将在获得资格的道路上前进。这是玛丽安·特伦特博士的“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣，各种通往成功的途径之多让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有完美的路径，这让我
filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
充满了信心，不再觉得自己做错了，也减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。